you probably remember this hilarious
moment from When Harry Met Sally and she
tells all huh stars while this
ridiculous rom-com scene is indicative
of a real and very serious sport which
Believe It or Not introduced society to
sport betting competitive walking better
known to some as pedestrianism started
in the 1800's aristocrats at that time
had footmen whose job was to carry
messages from one aristocrat to another
it was only a matter of time until the
aristocrats started making wagers on
whose footmen was faster
thus the birth of sport betting as we
know it competitive walking grew into a
real sporting event and reached its peak
in the 1870s and 1880s when spectators
would show up in super bowl-like masses
to see people walk competitively they've
even filled up the original Madison
Square Garden well sometimes races would
last up to six days in the atmosphere
was almost festival like brass bands
played vendors sold pickled eggs maybe
even some roasted chestnuts young the
competition's drew everyone from
celebrities to politicians even regular
folk champagne of all things was the
drink of choice for walkers they thought
it was a stimulant and as one would they
drank it by the bottle and guess what it
kind of worked one guy walked 136 miles
in just 34 hours bottoms up
you